قد لا ترى هذا المشهد يحدث في بلد كعمان
حيث درجات الحراره تصل الى اعلى معدلاتها
في الصيف وتكون معتدله في الشتاء ولكن
هذان الشابان العمانيين يستعدان لرحله
شديده البروده فبدر وامير سيذهبان الى
القاره الجنوبيه لاجراء بعض البحوث
واستعدادا للاجواء البارده هناك يق بعض
الوقت داخل هذه الثلاجه في
مسقط المره الاولى التي دخلنا فيها
الثلاجه كانت درجه الحراره 35 تحت الصفر
فشكل الامر صدمه لنا اليس كذلك نعم كانت
صدمه اذ كانت المره الاولى التي نتعرض
فيها الى هذا النوع من
البروده ولن تكون الاخيره فرحلت هما هي
جزء من مهمه تقودها مؤسسه
2014 وهي مؤسسه غير حكوميه تعنى بحمايه
القاره الجنوبيه ورغم بعدها عن سلطنه عمان
يرى الشبان الامور بطريقه مختلفه كان هناك
جبل جليدي ذاب عام 2010 وبلغ حجمه ما
يعادل مساحه قطر وذوبانه اثر بصوره سلبيه
على المحيطات التي تؤثر بدورها على
اليابسه ولدى العمانيين تاريخ طويل في
مجال الاهتمام بالبيئه فعمان تعتبر من
اكثر البلدان المتنوعه بيئيا وحمايه
البيئه اولويه هنا لمي ساعر رئيسه جمعيه
البيئه العمانيه تعمل مع الحكومه من اجل
ذلك نحن محظوظون جدا لنكون في زمن تنتعش
فيه السياحه والاقتصاد وعلينا احداث الفرق
والتعلم من اخطاء اقترفت في اماكن اخرى
حول العالم ولكن هناك الكثير من الامور
التي لازالت تنتظر التنفيذ خصوصا فيما
يتعلق بالتلوث فبدر يؤكد ان الامور تسوء
خصوصا على الشواطئ حيث كبور وتربى فحينما
كان طفلا علمه جده صيد السمك والسباحه هنا
وفي تلك الايام لم يكن هناك الكثير من
السكان وبالتالي لم تكن هناك نفايات كثيره
ولكن هذه الايام يقضي بدر جل وقته في
تنظيف الشاطئ بدلا من الاستمتاع به في اي
مكان على الشاطئ نجد شبكات الصيد المهمله
والنفايات في كل مكان لا يجب ان يحصل ذلك
في مكان جميل كهذا وهناك سبب اخر ياتي من
اجله بدر الى هذه الثلاجه مرتين في
الاسبوع لمده ست ساعات لزياده الوعي كما
كان على الشبين ايضا البحث عن سبل لتغطيه
تكاليف الرحله التي تصل كلفتها الى حوالي
28000 دولار وعلى ايه حال يبقى الترويج
امرا سهلا عبر استخدام وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي للتعريف بالقضيه وحال عودتهما
يخط تبدر لاطلاق حملته الخاصه من اجل
عمان اريد عوده وتعلم طرق جديده لحمايه
البيئه وتعليم الاخرين ايضا طرق المحافظه
على محيطهم وحتى ذلك الوقت يبقى الشابان
بانتظار مغامرتهما المرتقبه الى القاره
الجنوبيه